while we are blessed that many great
games are multi-platform these days
there are still plenty of absolutely
banging pc exclusives
for those who favor a keyboard and mouse
as well as games that could
only really exist in their true glory on
a pc
so i want to go through some of the best
pc exclusives 2020 has had to offer
so far now i want to point out you could
have been on this list boulders late
but no you had to go and delay
crusader kings 3 is a grand strategy
title of enormous
proportions with a staggering level of
detail and choice when it comes to the
growth of your characters
dynasty governance realms militaries
faiths
and much much more i have described it
as a strategy game that has made me feel
like an idiot while still absolutely
loving my time with it there is
definitely a learning curve when it
comes to creating your successful
kingdom
figuring out what the heck a casus belly
is what each law means
how your heirs in succession work and
why your kingdom can seemingly detonate
into civil war
at the drop of a crown a lot of the
impenetrable layers that have
traditionally been off-putting to
players in ck1 and ck2
were largely addressed with the release
of ck3 with the game being much more
accessible to newbie rulers
having extensive tooltip systems and
tutorializing
the whole country of ireland personally
while a big fan of strategy games and
the grand strategy elements that play a
huge part in crusader kings 3
i play it more as a virtual drama than i
do a game of conquest
with the options available to you when
it comes to leading your own ruler's
life
and influencing the lives of the
courtiers and dynasty members around you
some fascinating bizarre and hilarious
things can come to pass
like finding out your best son and heir
may not actually
be your child and choosing if you should
keep that secret to ensure that the
other children won't try to use their
lineage as an excuse to overthrow them
for the throne or you could decide to
conquer france by playing full habsburg
and keeping your bloodline pure
only for the pope to find out and
excommunicate you because
you're a lot of right old dirty buggers
crusader kings 3 creates some
real water cooler moments and bizarre
shareable stories
while its strategy is also deep enough
to strain the largest of brains
iron harvest is a universe where the
first world war was fought with giant by
peel mechs
and walking fortresses set in the diesel
punk world of 1920 plus
created by polish artist jacob rozelski
iron harvest is one of the best
and most interesting real-time strategy
titles i've seen in quite some time
it feels very reminiscent of company of
heroes in the ways it makes use of
terrain cover
units strengths and weaknesses but with
the addition of giant suits of armor and
behemoths that have scythes for hands
despite how it may sound units in
gameplay never feel
gimmicky or unbalanced a combatant
commander can make use of infantry for
flanking
using their anti-armor weapons and
hitting weak points can take down the
most powerful of mechs
giant robots can be taken down by swarms
of manpower surrounding them or if a
group of gunners are held up inside
buildings you can always just
walk that giant armored thing through
the brick and mortar
to deal with the issue units also have
their own special abilities
strengths and weaknesses that can be
drawn upon to change your play style
should the situation need it
its three factions also play pretty
differently if you want to lean into one
play style more than the other
with many of the mechanized roster
having attacks unique to that unit
as well as your army having their
special upgrades and their own suite of
heroes
i've been itching for a new rts game to
sink my teeth into for a good while
and as a big dawn of war and company of
heroes fan iron harvest takes a lot of
what made modern real-time strategy
titles
so enjoyable to play strapped a big
diesel engine on them
and created a game that will be
recognizable to long time strategy
gamers
but plays in its own unique way
[Music]
i still firmly believe that it would be
a massive challenge to replicate the
kind of experience that valerian offers
onto a controller the twitch-based
high-stakes composed and tactical style
of shooter gameplay
has always been at home on pc since the
early days of counter-strike
and valerian owes much of its dna to
that very same 1999 half-life mod
for those of you who haven't played
riot's free-to-play entry in the world
of first-person shooters
i often describe the game as
counter-strike with superpowers
it combines the objective and gunplay of
cs with agents built around gadgets and
abilities like in rainbow six
or in overwatch much of its backbone
makes it feel like a classic shooter
experience
but with enough sprinkled on top to make
sure it's unique and bespoke
to a class of shooter fans that can be
very
let's say discerning in an interview
with yours truly earlier this year
riot's own anna donald said
there's a way to play this game and
there's a way to experience this game
that we're not entirely sure translates
completely to console play
i don't know if we can ever break that
perception so we need to be
really really cautious about moving
forward on on those types of platforms
but i do think there's like something to
crack there
that our team is really excited to crack
and so what we've said is if we feel
like we can deliver this experience
on those platforms we will so for the
time being at least the pc space remains
the platform of choice
if you're after a shooter experience
like fallout or cs go
[Music]
half-life is so synonymous with pc
gaming it's still widely talked about
despite the fact that it has been just
shy of 13 years
since the release of episode 2. now i
know that the barrier for entry is
somewhat higher with half-life alex as
the prerequisite of a vr headset can be
a hefty expense
but that doesn't detract from the fact
that it is an incredible revisit to the
franchise
and elements you remember while still
being wholly unique to its own design
choices
with the power of valve behind it it's
no surprise that alex released
as one of the most highly polished
experiences that you can see through a
headset
and potentially one that can only truly
be appreciated through that medium
my favorite thing that half-life alex
does is to continue to build
on the world and story that surrounded
the silent gordon freeman for so long
tapping into recognizable characters
while also being something more focused
on its own story
it also brings a new genre of game
within that same universe
playing out more like a survival game
with resources fairly slim and head
crabs being way scarier
when they are on your actual but virtual
face
and we may have had the trip to
ravenholm and half-life 2 to spook us
but many sections straight up feel like
survival horror
but that may also be because i'm a
massive baby
it was a strange sensation but somehow
alex played like the half-life 2 i
remembered
but also obviously different in every
single way i think this game is also the
closest thing we've seen to a system
seller for the virtual reality market
everyone rushing to step back into the
world of the combine invasion
as if g-man himself were muttering the
words right into your ears
if you're once again tempted to visit a
virtual city 17 you may be in luck as
stock's vr headsets
are starting to return if you want to
know exactly what headset to go for
though we have a video we did a week
while back
reviewing the game on every available
device
to me squad sits on the first person
shooter spectrum
somewhere between the battlefield series
and armor which is unsurprising when you
take into account that members of the
development team
worked on battlefields project reality
mod now this game's been on my radar for
some time but i never got around to
playing it
until it was fully released and came out
of early access while squad has a drive
towards realism the main design tenant i
felt most deeply
is its focus on communication and
coordination it was quite jarring at
first
and i admit it took some time to get
used to but once you start to get into
that headspace you realize that these
huge
50v 50 battles complete with objectives
infantry and vehicles
would descend into unreadable chaos if
it wasn't for you taking the time to
communicate with the players around you
using voip within your squad or even
passing messages along to command v or
your own squad leaders
it's a punishing game for sure but as is
true with many games like this one when
all the pieces fall into place and you
feel like you're part of a cohesive team
the rush you get from overcoming
obstacles and playing as a small cog in
a giant firefight
or simply surviving an unexpected ambush
well the reward and gratification you
feel
far outweighs the struggle it took to
get there yes it's complex yes the
developers recommend you read a whole
damn wiki before you play
and no i don't think it's going to be
for everyone but squad sits so nicely in
that spectrum i mentioned earlier that
for the players that can appreciate both
ends
from battlefield to armor i highly
recommend giving squad a try
if you need a game to marvel at the
computing power of a pc or just need
something to make your gpu scream
then microsoft's flight simulator is
what you want other than being a game
that simulates real world planes and
lets you fly them like an absolute
maniac
microsoft flight simulator is absolutely
mind-blowing because of its ambition
to recreate every little bit of the
planet earth
right down to the street and building
you're in right now
it uses map data and some fancy ai to do
this
i wanted to get its fair share of
bizarre mistakes
like buckingham palace being replaced by
an office block it's pretty damn
impressive that other 99 of the time
that means with its free-form flight
mode you can drop your plane
anywhere you want from your house to the
north pole to
even the great pyramids if you fancy you
can control the time of day
the weather if you like volumetric
clouds and god-like lighting
or you can flip a switch and have the
game replicate real-world real-time
conditions
including current air traffic it makes
for some amazing virtual sightseeing
especially right now since well you know
the idea of flying a real world plane in
a simulation like this might be
daunting to you but you should be
pleased to know that microsoft flight
simulator has a bunch of assists
that can ease the whole burden on you
sure you could buy a flight stick and
use your mouse to manually flick
all the right switches in the cockpit
but the game also just lets you worry
about
going up and down left and right if you
just want to focus on having
a chill experience flying over your
favorite cities
microsoft flight simulator is one of
those games that feels like it's
heralding next gen
it's supposed to be coming to xbox at
some point who knows when
but of course pc is where you're going
to see all that cutting edge tech first
definitely something to fire up when you
get that 30 90 in the mail
eventually so those are some of the best
games that hold the title of pc
exclusives
in 2020 so far i may have missed out
some of your favorites so if so please
let me know in the comment section below
and if you enjoyed this video make sure
to hit the like button and stay
subscribed
to more pc gaming content at
gamespot.com
[Music]
you